what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with part five
of the white knight and god this story
just gets better and better it is so
intriguing it's it's so interesting cuz
it starts out it's like a stereotypical
Batman story then it turns into like the
Joker going sane and then it turns in
like this story's gonna reveal like
there's so many secrets in Gotham and
like so many things about that man that
we don't know but what this initially
does is it picks up with well really
with Jack Napier basically learning how
to become a better fighter now again one
thing I want you guys to bear in mind is
when it comes to him being sane this is
my routine popping of the pills it's not
permanent right like I mean if he stops
taking the pills he'll go back to being
the Joker
he's got the Joker at arm's reach but at
any point in time if Zoey took the pills
and like hid them he'd go back to being
the Joker again so it's cool because the
whole idea of him being sane just kind
of runs on the edge of a knife but him
learning how to fight from Harley Quinn
it's cool because what this is designed
to view is to show that he's basically
captured everything in fact that's
what's being said here in the
conversation between the two of them
Jack Napier's got it all he's got docked
port basically he's got the the support
of all the people in Gotham or at least
most of them he's got the support of the
Gotham City Police Department he's got
the support of Nightwing he's got the
support of Batgirl the only person who
support he does not have is Batman and
at the end of the day that doesn't
really seem to be a big part of the
picture anymore because when he looks at
where he is right now being a councilman
the idea that like he's somebody just
like training to fight Batman and
hand-to-hand combat that's really like
the one thing he's shooting for is he's
taken everything that matters to Batman
so all this left is to basically take
Batman's dignity to beat him in a
hand-to-hand fight and call it a day and
so at this point we switch over to Bruce
Wayne to Batman
who's basically going through and
investigating everything that's been
going on so far with regards to like neo
Joker and all that kind of good stuff
and the cool thing about this is that
initially as he goes down like he
immediately starts to pick up the pieces
and that's one thing I want you guys to
notice about Shaun Murphy's writing here
Batman's detective skills how
intelligent he is that's a bat that's an
afterthought it's a background thing
Shaun Murphy doesn't spend a whole lot
of time dwelling on that because it is
it's cool he doesn't treat us as the
reader as being stupid he's just kind of
like you guys know what's going on with
Batman
you guys know he's smart you guys know
he'll figure stuff out so let's worry
about other things going on it's very
reminiscent of like Scott Snyder Batman
but when he's sitting down you know of
course he's met by Barbara Gordon and
Nightwing and of course he deduces
within a matter of minutes the fact that
all the villains who have been operating
in Gotham
have all been mind controlled basically
that Clayface has something to do with
it because it's the one villain that
they haven't seen yet but the big
takeaway from this from this encounter
is that Nightwing and Barbara Gordon try
to convince Batman to join the GTO and
this is awesome because Batman's
response is no but notice his reasoning
here Batman doesn't simply say no
because you know like I don't trust the
GTO he says no because I don't trust
Jack Napier Batman is incapable of
letting go of the idea that Jack Napier
is the Joker and is a bad guy
Batman believes that like people can't
change that the Joker can't change and
that's was so ironic about this is
Batman's entire mission is predicated on
rehabilitation it's predicated on the
idea that a villain can basically be
redeemed and become a good guy
that's why he does it kill anybody but
the instant the Joker is redeemed well
then suddenly there's got to be
something going on it's basically one of
these things where like Batman has a
role to serve you as a purpose to serve
and he can't let it go Batman can't
function if there are no criminals in
Gotham and if Batman can't function
Bruce Wayne has no purpose and if Bruce
Wayne has no purpose then a purpose has
to be created and that's exactly what's
going on here to everyone who's looking
at Batman he's creating enemies because
he needs someone to fight someone out
there has to be wrong and that's why
this is so cool Dick Grayson is being
reasonable Barbara Gordon is being
reasonable Jack Napier's plan is is
really kind of like the perfect
compromise but Batman and his
stubbornness and his unwillingness to
admit defeat simply sits down assessed
but there has to be a caveat and that's
where things get kind of hairy because
for us as the reader we look at that and
we say well he's probably right because
I mean it's Batman
surely there has to be a catch but like
Athiya at the same time you look at this
and you say but what if there's not and
it really kind of like throws into sharp
relief the nature of whether or not
Batman is actually a hero and so at this
point we switch over to an encounter
with Batman and the real Harley Quinn
and the exchange is interesting here
because when it comes to Harley Quinn as
a character by and large Batman has
usually gone easy on her but the reason
for why Batman did this is because in
his mind Joker needed some kind of
counterbalance that if Joker did not
have something to anchor him as close to
reality as he could get then like he
would really fall off the defend Batman
says to Harley Quinn so he says we both
know that as bad as the Joker was we
knew how bad he wanted to be if you look
at Harley Quinn in this perspective this
human
it changes her in her entirety the
person that was keeping the Joker
anchored to reality she's his anchor and
without her he just falls down into the
path of absolute insanity really beyond
anything that he was before and that
also kind of brings into question is
that the reason why the Joker found a
second Harley Quinn but regardless of
the situation ultimately you know when
when Batman hits her up and says look
like you've got to find a way to set
things to rights her response is no like
I'm not siding with you Jack Napier is a
good guy he's not the Joker anymore if
you can't get past that and then the
problem isn't Jack Napier the problem is
you everyone is taking sides against
Batman it's really him against the world
metaphorically and in some ways
physically Gotham City against Batman
and so from here we pick up with neo
Joker and Mad Hatter now these two
trying to break into into Wayne Manor
this goes pretty par for the course in
this sense it like one you're talking
about like military-grade computer
systems but usually not like the the
highest levels of security in order like
access Wayne Manor to say nothing of the
computer in the Batcave and wear Mad
Hatter goes through and tries to hack in
different things like that
what is up happening his neo Joker
actually uses her ability to control
criminals and Breeze in poison ivy and
literally has her user vices start
snapping through and tearing down
different doors they're searching for
information that would connect the Wayne
family to the freeze family and the
freeze family was part of the German SS
back in World War two they're basically
trying to find a way to connect the dots
between Wayne and some pretty seedy
things that happened during the Second
World War and so as a result of this
poison ivy the various plants she uses
some of them are able to basically sense
like stale air indicating there's a room
with a door that hasn't been open in
forever and so they actually find the
room managed to tap in there but then
like Bruce Wayne realizes what's going
on when like you know the alarms go off
and this is hilarious this is what this
is one of the funniest parts of the
story because when they get in there and
they starts sniffing around they find
blueprints for like underground tunnels
different things like that suddenly
Bruce Wayne comes flying out of nowhere
god I hear you hooligans he's just like
this rich guy terrified for his life and
truth he could have just sort of lost it
and got gone after the two of them and
just started ripping things up I
remember when you're Batman you you kind
of recognize that sometimes the best
fight is the one that lasts the long
term it's the one where you gather all
the information that you need and having
like neo Joker in Mad Hatter busts into
his house and then starts searching
through a room where he could show up
his Batman is well let's follow them
let's see what's going on let's see what
they're doing and let's even check out
this room because one of the things we
find out
is that of course you have Nightwing who
responds as part of the gto and Batman
certainly sounds like they were in a
room that I didn't even know existed he
had no idea that it was there and so at
this point is really more questions
racing through his mind than answers but
the cool thing is that where night
wasted Lee says hey man looked like mr.
Wayne chill man the GTO has got this
what we end up having is him of course
you know basically donning his Batman
outfit now this is beautiful the way
that Shaun Murphy does this is
absolutely stunning because what we have
here is the GTO chasing after neo Joker
basically going after neo Joker and
going after Mad Hatter and they should
be able to take them out and in fact
they're catching up with them they're
able to hold their own some of the
criminals of neo Joker are being called
in to kind of you know back off and
force off some of the gto
but then you end up having like the
forces of backport that show up and so
they start taking out criminals too so
for the most part neo Joker and Mad
Hatter are effectively finished right I
mean it's only a matter of time they're
gonna chase them to a bridge or
something like that but it's only a
matter of time before they get caught
and then here comes Batman and what he
actually ends up doing is ruining
everything he screws it all up and
that's what's so great about this is
because we look at Batman as the guy who
shows up and saves the day Batman's a
superhero Batman saves the day that's
what Batman does instead like you have a
city that's basically able to stand on
his own two feet now that doesn't need
Batman anymore but he makes his presence
known Batman has to exist he has to be
there even if it means screwing things
up making things worse and so of course
where he grabs a couple of the documents
here he gets a hold of neo Joker but she
makes her escape
alongside Mad Hatter and he grabs a
couple of pages they basically show
Thomas Wayne next to one of the freezes
from world war ii the bridge ultimately
collapses and then you immediately have
Jim Gordon who says enough is enough
everybody's just fed up with Batman
they're tired of it how many resources
have been wasted because of Batman
here's a foolproof plan called the GTO
to basically have vigilantes and and the
Gotham City Police Department work
together and then here comes Batman and
a Love Field
you know ruining everything tearing
everything up mate you know kind of
reiterating the point of Jack Napier
Batman is not a superhero or a benefit
for Gotham City Batman's a liability
he's a hassle Batman is a pain in the
backside and Jim Gordon finally sees a
light and says Batman is no longer a
vigilante in the city of Gotham Batman
is a super criminal apv I want an APB
out all-points bulletin
Batman is to be arrested on sight and so
from here we
switch over to Bruce Wayne showing up at
the home of Victor fries showing up with
these documents smashing that that image
down on the paper you know a demo down a
local paper and says start talking and
mr. Freeze's response is the Wayne
family has many secrets they have a lot
of secrets but the most amazing part of
this drop off here is that Victor freeze
reveals to Batman that he knows that
he's Bruce Wayne how long he's known we
don't know but we know that he like he
knows that he's Bruce Wayne that's
what's so crazy about this without being
said guys we're to go ahead and ring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Robin Corps if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace